hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar newton's cradle exploring
rational and empirical design with
engineering biology i'm kaylee bach of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by inscripta to learn more please
visit inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
patrick j westfall senior director of
cell biology at inscripta
patrick you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
um we'll start off with a little bit of
introducing myself
and kind of how i came to to be at this
position to
talk to you today both uh the tools that
i've been part of building and the
experiences that i've had so
um i always like to start out with my
little grateful dead bears here and talk
about
my adventures in engineering biology so
far
started out
as a
undergrad at purdue university in west
lafayette indiana where i had my first
introduction to science working in a
undergrad lab you know washing the
dishes i think it's we're all all great
science starts with washing and having
clean dishes
from there i went on to the university
of georgia uh where i have my phd in
botany from the university of georgia in
athens georgia
and then from there i started my
post-doctoral work after my phd at ucsf
working with a doctor by the name of dr
ira herskowitz studying yeast signaling
and yeast physiology saccharomyces
cerevisia
and they continue that post-doc on over
at uc berkeley working with a
professional by the name of jeremy
thorner both of those were experts in
the field of yeast physiology and yeast
biology
after i finished my postdoc work i
entered into industry my very first job
was a scientist one at a company called
amherst biotechnologies located in
emeryville california
here i've got to work on
industrial in the industrial setting for
the first time
looking at making a classic compounds
called terpenes and engineering terpene
production
in microbes such as saccharomyces and e
coli that are then scaled up and produce
interesting novel molecules uh that go
into various products
from amaris end up going back to the
midwest into back up in indiana for a
while working for dow agri sciences at
indianapolis indiana this is where i got
my first introduction into genome
editing in this case not working on
microbes or mammalian cells but actually
working on plant cells looking at corn
and soybean and kind of those row crops
that you expect to see back in in the
great midwest and working on how to do
precision engineering using genome
editing technology to improve crop
performance
after my time at dow i end up going back
into the san francisco area i worked for
a company called xymergen where i was
the senior director for biological
engineering and exploratory research for
about four years and that's been
followed by the last year and a half
where i've been at inscripta
genome engineering technology tool
development company
as a senior director of the cell biology
group so throughout my career i've
always worked on on microbes with the
occasional dabbling implants
but brought a lot of products to market
and built a lot of interesting tools and
i kind of want to bring that experience
uh to the the seminar today and talk
about
um
how i've combined both the ideas of
rational engineering and really
hypothesis driven engineering
and combine those to make progress and
make products that are on market using
irrational means too
so if you're interested in
bringing products to market and this is
kind of in the industrial setting
although i think it has applications in
in the academic pure research setting
too
there are some things that you need to
to consider when it comes to strain
development it's a it's a complex
process and
making good choices at the very early
stages is absolutely critical to having
success and some of those early choices
include things like your strain
selection i've been in so many
conversations throughout my career about
hey do you work in an organism like e
coli or yeast that has a lot of tools is
really easy to work with
but doesn't necessarily scale in quite
the same way that you want it to it's
hard to take a yeast or an e coli and go
to 200 000 liters
or do you work with a strain that
already makes a product that already has
some natural attributes that makes its
acid tolerance or ph tolerant but
doesn't have the tools available so the
engineering may be more complex but
there's some inherent physiology that's
that's beneficial that will help you in
your scale-up process and those are
important decisions to make early on
you also are going to be working on
maximizing performance i spent so much
of my my graduate school and research
and postdoc and for me life existed on a
petri dish or in a shake flask and those
are important first steps but they have
nothing to do with what it looks like
when you're actually trying to scale a
product and produce it at 200 000 liters
and so things like how many grams per
liter tighter or how many grams per
liter per hour which is yield
am i getting in my product become really
really important because you can't run
giant fermenters indefinitely you want
to make product you want to make it fast
and at very high
levels and then your toolbox like i said
there this kind of ties back in the
stream selection
e coli and yeast have big tool boxes um
but you know may not be the best strain
to use so you need to develop a toolbox
for your organism of interest and you
know that toolbox means that you need to
have better strains better backgrounds
you need to know basic genetic elements
promoters terminators tags those types
of things and methodology is for rapid
testing at the end of the day
the proof is in the pudding as they say
and you need to actually measure your
outcome
and this is from a article in nature
back in 2010 when synthetic biology was
kind of really coming into into being
and there's five hard truths that
synthetic biology we need to consider as
you if you think about trying to scale a
process
uh and those truths are that many of the
parts are undefined you know physiology
cell biology is very complicated um so
there may be parts of the of the genome
parts of the the overall metabolic
pathway that you don't understand that's
not defined this is not predictable
uh the circuitry is unpredictable you
don't know if you put a strong promoter
quote unquote strong promoter in front
of a gene if it's really going to be
strong expression there's a lot of other
things that go into the regulation of
the gene or of a pathway you're trying
to
uh you know engineer
the complexity is unweirdly you know
factorially you look at some of these
metabolic pathways that go into making
products and they have you know multiple
genes if not hundreds of genes in some
case that all contribute to the ultimate
output and that complexity gets very
very uh overwhelming very very quickly
many of the parts that you're trying to
work with are incompatible um they look
good on paper but when you actually go
and use them it's not compatible with
your system and finally that the
variability crashes the system um we
seem to think about you know culture and
bacterial engineering
um you know this this thing in a
fermenter or this thing in a shake flask
this thing in a shake plate but reality
is that we're looking at the mean of the
productions of millions and millions of
microbes and in that and that mean and
then that variability uh you know one
cell mutating can overtake the system
and crash it uh if it stops producing it
starts growing instead
so how do you how do you combat this how
do you deal with this well the way to
deal with this
as we'll talk about today is
generate a lot of diversity generate a
lot of large space where you can look uh
for winners there there's an idea
there's there's an old joke about a
man's out in the parking lot looking
under a light and a police officer walks
up to him and says
you know what are you looking for he's
like oh i dropped my keys and the office
said oh around here he goes no over
there in the dark but this is where the
light is as scientists we tend to look
where the light is we tend to look only
in those things that we know but to
really make progress as we'll talk about
today
you want to look everywhere as much as
broadly as possible and that means you
need to generate a lot of diversity and
you need to look take that diversity and
then combine it as quickly as possible
so to start out with um there's an
analogy that i i like to use so as a as
a kid growing up my dad had a uh i guess
the term today would be a a man cave or
a cave and in that uh basement he had a
had a bar a wet bar and on top of the
bar was a bunch of what i guess we
referred to as bar games we had dart
boards and those types of things but one
of the things that sat on top of his bar
was this
uh old i don't know if it's a toy or
what it is but it's called newton's
cradle and it's the idea that uh the
conservation of motion you have these
five steel balls hanging by a thread and
you take the one on the end and you let
it go and it swings back and forth and
that conservation of motion means that
only the outer balls will actually go
back and forth and so this is the
analogy that i want to use
as we approach biological engineering or
engineering biology and think about it
in this context of newton's cradle
and in the context of newton's cradle to
go back to a cartoon image here if
newton's cradle is engineering biology
you have these two extremes that that
kind of follow this conservation of
motion
on on the left hand side you have
empirical engineering these are the
things that
you're engineering for that space that
you don't know the unknown unknowns if
you will
um the approaches you take in empirical
engineering are selections uh you do
mutagenesis you look for an improved
phenotype some way but you're not
intentionally
engineering a pathway or engineering a
gene you're just looking at diversity
expressly for the idea of trying to find
some sort of improvement
at the other extreme is hypothesis
driven engineering and this is what
a lot of synthetic biology likes to
embrace but as we just talked about it's
highly complicated and very difficult to
work through the space where everything
is purely rationally driven
um both are useful you need to have both
approaches but the reality is if you
just have one
um to all exclusion you're going to get
stuck you're not going to make progress
so thinking about this this newton's
cradle thinking about those five areas i
think you start with the centerpiece
that center steel ball and what is this
center piece the piece that doesn't move
the piece that is is i guess the the no
unknowns and that is your core knowledge
so when you start a project when you
start doing your engineering you know
the organism are you going to work in
yeast are you going to work in e coli
you're going to work in bacillus so you
know the organism you know it's
physiology you know what you can feed it
and what you can't beat it and for the
most part at this point we know it's
metabolic pathways we know how it's
going to consume sugar or some other
metabolite we know how that carbon can
flow to the system we can measure that
so this is the the core knowledge of
things that are have been known for a
while or can be known that are pretty
you know immobile the middle ball
doesn't move you don't see any motion in
the middle ball it stays there
now you kind of move a step out you go
either direction and as you go towards
the empirical engineering direction now
you start to make assumptions you you
have problems like is your product toxic
you know are there regulatory networks
are you know is there some sort of
feedback mechanism is there enzyme
evolution where an enzyme doesn't have a
k cat or a km that is quite right and
you want to improve that k cat km
i call these assumptions because these
problems will arise but you don't
necessarily have a rational approach on
how you're going to fix them if it's
toxic do you evolve the cells in the
presence of the products that overcomes
that toxicity if it's regulatory
networks do you change out the promoters
and terminators so you have a regulatory
element that is under your control if
it's enzyme evolution do you do
saturation mutagenesis across that
entire enzyme looking for some variant
that gives you a better k cat or km
so there are things that you can know
about but you don't know the solution
set
on the other hand if you go to the right
to the more hypothesis-driven
engineering now you start to look at
what we call metabolic engineering for
the most part there's a knowledge base
that you can you know actually track and
measure things so for example metabolic
flux you can feed radioactive carbon to
a cell and follow those carbons through
the cell through the process and
actually measure that
you can look at redox balance same way
look at your nadh and adph and look how
that changes over time you can actually
measure this and in those measurements
you know something and in that knowledge
you can then engineer to say adjust the
redox balance so that it is balanced and
you do have the right amount of nad and
nadph at the end of your pathway so
everything works out you're not losing a
bunch of energy into turning over that
that redox balance
and finally we find ourselves out at the
the edges
really where a lot of the work takes
place where that motion and newton's
cradle takes place so again we'll go to
the empirical engineering the a rational
engineering if you will
and over here you're left with tools
like evolution you know can can cells
under a certain strain or a certain
stress evolve to produce a phenotype of
interest to you you can speed evolution
up by doing mutagenesis adding uv or ems
something to essentially intentionally
damage the dna and the cell and in that
damage make some sort of change that
hopefully has a beneficial effect or you
can do even to some extremes which is an
advent that's more recently part of the
synthetic biology world which is genome
scanning where you go and look at the
promoter the regulatory element in front
of every single open reading frame
in the genome and change them all
at once or all you know singularly and
see does that have an effect
on the other end you have your
hypothesis driven research
and this is strain improvement where
you're very intentional so you put in a
pathway of knowing kinetics of known
biology
you look at it
you know heterologous enzymes that
intentionally you've picked out to see
if they have better properties you're
putting them in the genome and looking
at performance this is what we call
pathway engineering pathway insertion
there's a part of this also that goes
back to the fermentation the scale which
is process control so in some cases you
may have a product that is sensitive to
nitrogen so you can control that in your
fermentation process
but all very
rational intentional thoughtful ways to
engineer
a particular organism
and so what you have is this in order to
make progress to really do it if you're
only in one extreme you can make some
progress but you're eventually going to
get stuck and you can go back and forth
and it's through this back and forth
that you make progress that you are able
to bring products to market quickly that
you're able to make strain improvements
very very quickly
you can look there are some examples
that are are really well known in which
case you did
have one extreme and there's products on
the market that came from that one
extreme so over here on the left under
the a rational engineering there's
penicillin a great story penicillin
discovered in world war ii
saves has saved
millions of lives over the years but
honestly it was isolated from a moldy
cantaloupe out of peoria illinois from
the back of a grocery store in peoria
illinois and they took that moldy
cantaloupe they were able to culture in
these flat bottom flask
rooms and rooms and rooms for these flat
bottom flasks to
uh get penicillin they could then treat
soldiers in in world war ii
uh it's amazing what they did
considering they had no
rational engineering tools they used
strictly mutagenesis and this is the
first example of mutagenesis ever being
used to make a product where they just
blasted the cells and selected cells
that made more of this penicillin
compound
and within a year and a half through
scale to working with merck and pfizer
in the usda they went from having
something that made literally milligrams
per liter of cell culture to
enough penicillin to treat every single
soldier who was injured on the stormy of
the beaches of normandy an incredible uh
example of
progress made through
mutagenesis and engineering and scale up
process
another example is citric acid so citric
acid is made by a filamentous fungus
called aspergillus niger
and what you have here on the left is a
picture of what that aspergillus niger
looks like it has these kind of fluffy
ball heads that
contribute to mold the mold spores
however when you actually take citric
acid and put it in production for food
preservatives or for making
soda these types of things it's really
really important industrial chemical it
changes its morphology and it has this
kind of clustered shape that looks very
very different than what the wild type
aspergillus looks like
and it's amazing this was all done again
through selection through a rational
means through just looking for
phenotypes that allow this to grow in
large scale fermentation processes
what's amazing is you look on the left
you look what's on the right the
differences between those two strains is
only about
40 changes 40 changes in the genome that
consists of millions and millions of
base pairs results in that drastic
scientific change and it goes from
something that's moldy and gross to
something that makes a product that we
use in everyday life
another one i like this is a product
that i actually got it got to touch bit
a little bit when i worked at dao agra
sciences called spinosun
great story here where some engineers or
some scientists from eli lilly were down
in the virgin islands on vacation and
back in the 80s it was very typical for
these pharmaceutical companies who are
looking for new natural products to send
their employees out with little plastic
bags and ask them to take soil samples
and bring soil samples back and then
they would culture organisms from those
that soil and say hey does it make
anything that has a particular phenotype
that we like so one of their employees
was at a rum factory down in the virgin
islands had a little plastic bag took a
soil sample from that rum factory
outside that rum factory brought it back
and they were able to propagate this
actinomycete called
sacropolysporospinosa
and it turns out it makes a compound
called spinosun and that compound is a
great insect repellent it's used by
alanko has a topical treatment to treat
your pets for fleas and ticks it's also
used in the agricultural space has a
spray to prevent insects for especially
crops like blueberries
it's been engineered over the time it's
selected from a soil sample and it's
been engineered over time
through muted cereal mutagenesis with
very little hypothesis-driven
engineering to make the product we use
today
and finally what i'm going to come back
to is is lysine and lysine's made by a
bacteria called chronic bacterium and
you'll see a picture here of a movie
that came out quite a while back called
from uh called the informant with
starring matt damon and we'll talk about
why this is important in a second but
again this is a example of a product
that comes naturally from a microbe that
already existed that's been
mutated over years to make super high
levels of lysine if you ever drive
through
decatur illinois and there's a smell in
the air that smell is these large
fermentations from adm producing lysine
from chronic bacterium
now in the last 20 years uh really we've
seen a shift from that kind of pure
empirical engineering over to the more
hypothesis driven engineering so here
we're looking at products where although
maybe some empirical methods were used
they were largely hypothesis driven and
one of the first products ever came to
market was one three propane diol which
was a collaboration between uh tate and
lyle and
um dupont and this is a small molecule
it's produced in e coli and it's used to
make sustainable plastics so it's
plastic not made from petroleum but
plastic made from fermentation
another one and one that i've actually
personally worked on uh is a product
called artemisinin so this was a project
that was sponsored at my very first job
at amherst by the bill melinda gates
foundation
where
it was identified this plant shown on
the right artemisia annua
was identified as making an active
compound back in the late 60s that would
allow uh soldiers to be treated for
malaria so it was it was developed used
as a tea by the by the chinese who are
supporting the north vietnamese
and when their soldiers would come down
to malaria they brew a tea from the
leaves of this plant and that their
soldiers would get better so in the late
60s they identified the active compound
artemisinin the problem was that because
it only came from the plant the supply
was really really unstable so you
couldn't get enough of the artemis and
on top of that because of the structure
of the compound
it wasn't really stable to produce so it
didn't have a very short shelf life and
so what the people at amherst did the
group that i was part of is we took the
genes out of this plant artemisia annual
we engineered them in the saccharomyces
cerebesia the yeast shown here on the
left we were able to make artemisinin
through fermentation of yeast and since
basically stabilize that supply of
anti-malarial drug so that anybody who
needs to get treated for malaria can now
have access to artemisinin it's not
seasonally dependent
it also had the benefit of really
stabilizing the supply the price and
supply chain
and finally another example of a product
that
you know we we
use through rational engineering and
this is a sweetener called rev m so
there's several companies out there who
are working on
engineering some sort of microbes either
e coli or saccharomyces to
make this uh a particular sweetener
that's normally found in plants engineer
that pathway into microbes and produce a
large-scale substitute for pure cane
sugar
that has all the quality but none of the
calories of sugar so all the sweetness
but none of the calories of sugar
and you know at the end of the day i
give these examples that are kind of
extreme examples but you know
the problem becomes i think and what my
hypothesis that i'll argue that if
you're overly indexed any one of these
approaches
you'll find yourself back into a corner
you'll find yourself kind of at a local
local local max but it's not the
ultimate max and really if you want to
make progress quickly and i've seen this
time and time again it's even with all
those products that i've worked on uh
that you need to have this back and
forth between hypothesis-driven
engineering putting the pathways in and
then empirical engineering looking
broadly to make progress and so this is
where your newton's cradle comes in
where you're going back and forth you
know you go hypothesis-driven then you
hit you back to your core knowledge and
you go empirical and oftentimes when you
find yourself in these bottlenecks you
can get out of that empirical space by
doing rational engineering or if you
find yourself in a rational corner you
can get out of it by doing empirical
engineering
which brings kind of to the next part of
you know where technology is going where
we are today and i always like this
quote this is a scientist mathematician
from from britain named freeman dyson uh
he's fought a little bit out of favor
because he was a very big climate denier
but i don't think him being a climate
denier actually
i don't think him being a climate denier
changes the idea that this is a true
concept and his quote is new directions
in science are launched by new tools
much more often than by new concepts the
effect of a concept-driven revolution is
to explain old things in a new way the
effect of a tool-driven evolution is to
discover things that have yet to be
explained
and on this next slide
i kind of talked through this because uh
in my 20 years of doing you know
biological engineering the tools have
changed and the way the tools have
changed have allowed us to make progress
quicker
i talked about being an undergrad doing
research at purdue university back then
it was an entire phd in you know in the
late 80s early 90s to just to clone a
gene or two to clone and sequence a gene
or two was your phd
now you know cloning the gene is simply
a click button order from idt or from
twist or for one of the many vendors and
you get it two or three days later in
some cases
so what used to take you know five years
can now be done essentially overnight
uh and so what i have here and the kind
of the upper left corner is is how we
think about the the engineering cycle
when it comes to training engineering
which we call design generate test and
learn and scripta
and think about how design has changed
so that left corner which i realize is
kind of hard to see this was the very
first
genome editing program i ever used it
was called gene runner
and if you still look online you can get
the abandonware version of this but it
was literally these chunky blocks of acs
gs and keys that you could go in and
engineer on windows nt
now compare that to
the designer software that inscripta has
worked with so whereas i would have to
work with a 500 base pair chunk of dna
that i uploaded myself and scripta's
automated design software and other
design software's out there allow you to
upload the entire genome at once and
engineer and make designs that will
allow you to engineer the entire genome
um if you would have thought about what
it would take it would taken weeks if
not months if not years to engineer in
that old generator platform the types of
things that the designer platform and
enscripta
or other designer platforms out there
can do in a matter of hours
so the software has been obviously a
huge impact into this engineering
biology
revolution think about the generate part
automation so
most of my early career was spent
holding one of these blue rain and
pipettes we still all have them and
removing clear liquids from tube to tube
it got better here's an example of
automation this is a t-can robot where
also we can move liquid from two tube 96
at a time
uh and then we'll talk about today a
little bit is let's get rid of all the
plastic ware let's get rid of all those
tubes and let's look at the individual
cells and that's where this onyx
platform
comes in and the tools around designed
around onyx using genome editing
technology that looks you let you look
at massively parallel libraries
all at once
in you know screens and selections in
such a way that you don't need to move
clear liquid from tube to tube
when it comes to tests i i mentioned you
know used to be a big deal to
sequence a single gene for your phd and
that's kind of what this gel shows for
those of you who may have been around
for a while uh this is an old school s35
polyacrylamide gel that you exposed to
a film and then you would depending on
which lane that band showed up in would
tell you if it's an a c g or t and you
could maybe get a couple 100 base pair
read from this very clue g gel system uh
now contrast that to a my seek where i
get my whole genome sequence back the
next day
in addition the analytical equipment uh
you know this is the typical gc mass
spec um i still remember i was so proud
of myself when i programmed my first gc
i could detect the compound of interest
in 26 minutes per sample it was awesome
now you have things like rapid fire mass
effect where that same sample can be
sampled in seconds and you can test
thousands of samples so the tools on the
test side have really really improved
allow us to make progress really really
quickly
and then coming back to the software um
you know i put the the picture of gene
runner up here uh if i did make a change
i did do sequencing i had to upload my
new sequence back into gene runner and
then look
base pair by base pair to see if it was
there it was very very time intensive uh
very very kludgy
compare that now to what we kind of get
back from
software where you can look at a whole
genome and say right there that base
pair changed everything else the genome
is exactly the same but this is the
change that we made
again in a process that takes
maybe a day or two at the very most it's
incredible the speed at which we can
move now because
these tools are available the knowledge
base i would argue to do some of these
things has been around for a long time
but these tools allow us to do more of
it do it more rapidly
and do it with higher uh precision and
and quality
which brings us to the onyx platform and
so i'm going to go through some examples
uh of where this onyx platform now we're
showing the instrument here but it is
the software it is the
way we design our our architecture is
the way we use genome editing so we look
at it at the back end to get the the
answers that we want
um but the onyx platform in this case is
a tool that's been developed by
inscripta uh and it ties back into what
i was talking about doing rational and
empirical approaches these are the
examples i'll give
this platform
allows you to look very very broadly but
also in some cases very very
intentionally to make progress you can
make libraries of tens of thousands of
variants all at once screen those
variants and find improvements uh in a
matter of days uh it would used to be
processes that would take months at a
time to identify the improvements and
stack them
and what makes this different what makes
this different is this idea of if you
wanted to do rational engineering in
traditional manners companies i've
worked for
do this now uh you have to go and let's
say in this case we're going to use
crispr uh you want to have an
intentional design you have to take your
strain you have to put it into an
individual well of a 96 well plate you
have to provide your guide rna in the
case the crisper your cast 9 system of
some sort
and your donor dna is separate pieces
those all have to be you know aliquoted
and hit picked out into individual wells
you can do this 96 at a time and scale
as it is appropriate
the onyx platform takes those individual
pieces of individual partitions and we
actually make the cell itself the
partition and we do this by combining
the guide rna and the donor rna all into
one construct and then barcoding it such
that each cell
gets a unique
editable
system
then the edible system
the cells can be transformed they'll
take up this dna the guide rna will
guide the cut the donor
the donor dna will guide the the paste
and then when you have a cell that looks
like a winner that has a phenotype is of
interest all you have to do is do a very
simple pcr
and uh saying your sequencing reaction
read the code and say oh i made a change
in this gene and here it is uh it's
incredibly fast incredibly efficient and
uh the part that i like is you go from
going through this number of 96 well
plastic plates to a much much smaller
number so
i like the green aspect of it too you
don't use nearly as many plastic tips
and all my time as a postdoc and a grad
student going from tube to tube with
clear plastic
p10 pipette tips can be replaced
by this kind of high-throughput rapid
bar-coded genetic system
so
uh that's that's the idea of of tools
and and the impact that they have on
uh engineering biology how they can
benefit both in the rational empirical
matter i'm going to have some examples
i'm going to go through next
so
the first one i'll go through is is a
detailed example on kind of pathway
improvement and i like this example
because i want to bring back uh matt
damon in this movie the informant
i grew up in central illinois not too
far from decatur which is where adm's
located
and adm
at the time was subject to one of the
largest sec finds ever it turns out that
adm
a company out of japan called ajinomoto
a company out of korea called jail dong
all these people who were producing
lysine which is a small amino acid
that's used in animal feed
we're essentially including to price fix
and drive the price of lysine up
artificially high and
the informants is a movie about an
insider at adm who basically whistle
blew to the sec about this price fixing
and at the time the fine that was given
kind of this is a short part over here
in the department of justice was the
highest fine ever given by the sec
to a company
for price fixing
so um
lysine itself like i said it's a
valuable commodity if you drive through
decatur illinois you can spell the
lysine tanks you can see the lysine
tanks they're impressive 600 000 liter
tanks that are are pumping out this
small amino acid
and then feeding it to
pigs and chicken as part of the
um you know way to to get them up to the
the growth that the things can go into
our food production
the lysine pathway itself is is very
straightforward there's 19 core genes in
the pathway uh 26 transcription factors
kind of on the left here you can see uh
that core pathway all the the genes
involved if you just took out all the
metabolism and drew straight lines from
gina gene that's what the pathway would
look like
and so
um we wanted to do a proof of
proof of concept showing that this
combination of both rational and
a-rational engineering of looking
broadly could have an impact and and
quickly make progress to improve strains
uh that we're making valuable chemicals
like lysine or valuable molecules like
lysine and so the approach that we took
is knowing those core 19 pathways we
looked across the entire genome we
designed uh libraries on the
onyx platform using the software that
combined i guess what you'd call
semi-rational ideas so you went through
the genome and you knocked out that's
what ko stands for here in this kind of
circle you design
made designs that knock up every single
gene in e coli independently of whether
you thought it hit the lysine pathway or
not and i call this kind of a
rational a-rational because
rationally you're making knockouts but
irrationally you're looking at
everything at once
on top of that we looked at uh you know
kind of the core uh genes in e coli
and uh looked at every single gene so
the ones that were not absolutely
essential so 3676 genes and we took the
promoter the driver in front of every
one of those genes and replaced it with
a novel promoter of varying strength so
what you can see on the right here is a
promoter ladder so these are our
promoter sequences that are of varying
strength so the idea is if you put this
sequence in front of a gene it will
have some effect on that gene either
make that gene express higher or make
that gene express lower and what you can
see here is we picked five different
strengths of promoters out of this
library provided by igem
and we rationally engineered but then a
rationally across every gene
one of these promoters in front of
every single gene so we have five
different promoter strengths in front of
every single gene and then we screened
it
so rationally we put a promoter in front
of your gene rationally knocked out
everything but we also a-rationally
looked at everything at once
and this is what the outcome is we
looked at 18 000 isolates
and then we looked at okay the mean here
is shown as zero
and we look for those things that really
had an impact either increase the amount
of lysine coming out or decrease the
amount of lysine coming out sometimes
you learn things that have negative
effects
and so looking there at that kind of of
space you can see that there's a number
of things in the far left in that
knockout collection that improve
production of lysine there's a number of
things in this what we call the pathway
so these are the core genes of the
pathway those 19 genes where we either
did promoter swaps put different
promoters in front of it did a small
saturation library where we changed the
amino acid that was already on on a
particular
gene in that pathway to a arginine or a
histidine or asparagine
or we did the promoter swap shown here
on the far right we took those libraries
that had a total of 200 000 designs we
screened 18 000 of them on a rapid fire
mass spec that took seven seconds per
sample
and in that space we found some really
interesting things so for example one of
the genes that's really key to this
pathway is called dap a
uh it's feedback inhibited by lysine
so we looked at this one saying okay
what's that feedback inhibition let's
look at every single amino acid on this
enzyme and let's change it let's do site
direct immunogenesis and change it to
every one of the other 19 amino acids
that possibly could be it's also nice we
had a control built in here so one of
these amino acids e84 we could change to
a threonine
tyrosine sorry uh threonine anyway get
my get my amino acids mixed up here
but this is a validated hit that was in
in the literature and
in this case we knew that if this one
came up we were going to get an
improvement in the light scene
um uh hit here so we we had something
internally we knew that this would come
up in our design library
and so we made progress so
going here to a background and these are
color coded by the various uh kind of
engineering that was done so you start
over on the left hand side with wild
type and this is the amount of lysine
produced
by wild type the red bar at the top of
the graph shows where this
you know e84 to tyrosine
mutation is
and that's that's what we want to get to
so that's the baseline so the wild type
actually well it produces below that
line and if we just looked in the
background at either genome-wide
knockouts or genome-wide promoter spots
thrown in blue and green here we could
find that there are certain genes that
we could hit
looking in this background of this
already improved variant that would
actually push our
production of lysine up even higher
we then started stacking those heads to
combine those hits so you start out with
e84t and all of a sudden we find this
dapp a
that same version but within one of
these promoters that came out of the
promoter library and so we have now a
970x production increase over what the
wild type strain was producing
we continued to screen these libraries
and now we combine these hits we stack
these hits so both that promoter on dapa
allows as well as that point mutation
and now we're up to 10 000 times higher
production of lysine
and then on top of that you start
looking at other places in the genome
that had a positive impact so in this
case the gene glnd with a strong
promoter has now given us a 14 000 x
production improvement of lysine i think
the other thing to point out to you is
if you wanted to do this kind of
engineering it would normally have taken
you months and months and months and uh
to go through this this
design this both empirical and rational
approach we were able to do this in 14
000 x improvement in lysine production
in about five weeks uh using the onyx
instrument using this technology that
combines um the various aspects of
rational irrational approaches
and so you know at the end of the day
you can look at the protein you can look
at the pathway you can look at the
genome the approach that i just showed
you here as an example
hits all these the protein specifically
the pathway generally and the genome
writ large
and you get about a total of two
thousand two hundred thousand edits in
this case
um but what you can see here is if you
actually have a plot a graph and so
uh this is this is the graph of
production in two different medias so
kind of a rich media then a production
media
and you look at where these hits are
these winners that you are that led to
that drastic improvement in lysine so
you want things in the upper right
corner
you want things that are improved in
both the media conditions you want to
test
and you can get there very very quickly
it took five weeks and look at all these
hits that were
generated and some of these had never
been seen before these were all
in some cases there was the control but
in many of these cases all these dots
you're seeing here all these
improvements you're seeing here are
things that we didn't know about the
complexity of biology and lysine
production that we can now uh look at
and and design the next library and
design the next week to push that
production even higher
real quickly here i got a couple other
examples that that may be relevant to
products that are important in the in
the bioeconomy
the next example is specifically around
protein production
again combining this this rationale of
using both
you know
intentional ideas promoter swaps
genome-wide knockouts with also looking
large across the whole genome so in this
case this is an example
done internally at inscripta we are
using saccharomyces cerevisia has our
our base strain a background called zpk2
and we inserted a heterologous protein
called cbh1 so cbh1 is a
cellobiohydrolase
it's really important in the production
of using cellulosic feedstocks
converting cellulosic feedstocks to
sugar for production of valuable
chemicals or ethanol
so think about the ethanol plants back
in the midwest you're feeding corn
stover to be able to break down that
corn stove into workable
carbon that can be converted into
biofuels is really important so this is
what cbh1 does
and so one of our scientists eric abate
who's part of our applications
development group uh sat down at his
computer and in a couple hours generated
seven different libraries uh that he
employed in parallel and these seven
libraries
included genome-wide knockouts uh
genome-wide terminator insertion so the
three prime end was changed out
and deletions across the entire genome
in addition
so those are kind of those unbiased
genome-wide
knockouts
in addition he did some rational
engineering where he did
basically transcription factor binding
sites so tfbs stands for transcription
factor binding sites and he did these
promoter insertions all across the
genome and certainly in front of the
physicians in cbh1 in addition he did
enzyme engineering where he took that
cbh1 gene and did
codon changes changed every single amino
acid to all the other possible amino
acids
so these libraries were rather big
but in this idea that you don't have to
look at everything to exhaustion you can
just screen a subset and find hiss
that's exactly what he did so for
example uh in one library that had 5000
different designs he only screened about
a thousand of those
so only you know a small percentage of
the coverage but he was able to get
eight unique hits um that we wouldn't
have gotten through purely rational
means
and that's what's kind of shown here at
the top so again looking at that chart
these are the various tips from the
library the baseline is one at the very
bottom you see it's divided into
genome-wide
looking versus targeted looking on the
gene on the around the gene around the
pathway
you get a nice combination of both
rational irrational hits
and you can get a pretty drastic change
in
production
over that base strain and then you have
the ability to go and combine this and
the thing that i think is great all
these changes this would you know
honestly i can say in previous jobs
these kinds of changes these types of
libraries would have taken months if not
years to generate
eric by himself was able to generate
this data three months start to finish a
couple hours to design the libraries
wait for the oligos to get built
delivered back to him
transform the strains on the instrument
and then screen those strains and at the
end of the day he found 74 unique hits
that had not been reported in the
literature that had a positive impact on
production of this particular protein
and then to kind of round it out i want
to give one other example and this has
to do so if this is protein production
how much protein you can make this has
to do with protein function
enzymology if you will
in this case one of our collaborators
over at vib in in europe had four key
genes that were involved in
membrane generation so these are the
four genes shown here in the purple red
and orange boxes
and
she wanted to explore changing every
single amino acid to every other
possible amino acid across these four
proteins
and what's really cool is with the onyx
system this was not a labor-intensive uh
process this didn't take very long she
uploaded her genome picked her four
genes and said do substitutions click
the button uh and then it generated the
the various edits so in the case of lpxa
for example all 527 edits were generated
at a click of a button
and what you show over here on the right
is is a heat map so at the bottom is the
the residue which position which amino
acid position on the left hand side is
the the single letter code for every
single amino acid that could be
substituted in this case and if you look
very carefully at the top you see these
little bitty dots
these little bitty dots from all the
work that have been done for for many
many years in these four proteins these
little bitty dots are the residues that
were shown to be
uh important and vital
in membrane generation
across these four genes and what's
amazing to me is it's a relatively small
set competing considering the
combinatorial space of these four genes
and all the amino acids you could make
and then when you look at the heat map
what you can see is if you look in the
horizontal direction you see these kind
of patches of white and if you look
closely you'll see for example proline
is a very
uh poorly tolerated substitution so you
kind of see a horizontal line at the p
there saying that hey amino acid
substitution of proline at every one of
the amino acids isn't a good choice to
make
but you looked at every single amino
acid that's not always the case now if
you look at the at the
vertical line what you can see is that
we're able to identify essentially
residues that are critical um and that's
this basically if you look uh from top
to bottom or bottom to top
if you see a basically a white line this
means that this is a residue that is
critical
that is important it does not tolerate
substitution very well so these are
other key residues that you might want
to go after to understand the
functionality of this enzyme
and so
you know this is a much fuller map a
much more detailed map on the enzyme
space that you can explore uh things
that you can go after things that you
can substitute for uh things that you
don't want to do but it's a
comprehensive map that allows you to
go on to the the next
national approach to improve these
enzymes
and then finally one final example
and this is the idea of
taking a traditional methodology and
doing what they call decompolation
finding out the the key changes that
might have happened in a change over
time so
uh there's a process called adaptive
laboratory evolution so this is the idea
that you want a a strain or a cell to be
more tolerant to some stress say
heat or ph or in this case acid
tolerance
so over the years uh through various
literature-based methodologies there are
992
e coli strains that have been generated
uh that shows some sort of acid
tolerance
uh
you know in these 992 strains there are
372 identified variants
168 transposon insertions and 542
knockouts all that for some reason or
another
give you a phenotype that makes you acid
tolerant
uh so what our collaborator did is it
took all 992 of these changes and said
okay which ones are are really important
which ones can really give me the best
acid tolerance
and he designed those as part of the
inscriptive platform so this is informed
by a rational mutagenesis but now it's a
rational library and he was able to take
all 992 of those unique elements put
them into a single library expose them
to this case chameric acid and say okay
which one make my cells more resistant
which one make them less resistant and
find genes that are are really key
again you want to look at that that far
upper right con quadrant say what are
those things that
truly make me the most acid tolerant and
then you can then map those residues of
those genes that change in this case
looking at rna polymerase subunit alpha
so rpoa
and say okay
these green residues and the in the
crystal structure make the cell uh make
the the protein make the the cells more
tolerant to acid
those in red or critical they make it
less tolerant
so
it's a way to to take you know what
would be a really really hard to do a b
testing across 992
unique snips or unique changes it's a
way to do it all at once and let your
winners rise to the top and uh make
progress and and back towards either
basic science or to the production of a
of a protein or a cluster of proteins
here that are important to uh conferring
acid tolerance which is important at
scale
so those are my examples i think we have
some some time left for questions i'm
going to go ahead
and pause here and let the moderator
come back and and let me know if there's
any questions i can answer for anybody
who listens
thank you patrick for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks
one of the limitations of empirical
engineering is an appropriate screening
method often we are stuck with
growth-based assays is this instrument
capable of screening for
non-growth-based phenotypes such as
production and if so
how
what screen does it use cytometry
perhaps right
uh
so so with relate relation to this what
the instrument does is it allows you to
design it does the transformations for
you it basically normalizes the cell so
you have a library that's equally
representative
what comes out the back end though um
is a
pool of cells
enough to do your experiments but what
we can't
really predict is what people are going
to do with it are you looking to make um
furnacing are you looking to make a a
poly key type are you looking to make
whatever your product is because
everybody's product is unique
um you know we're not in a position to
dictate what your
screen or your selection should be now
with that being said um you know those
limitations things like cytometry become
very important we've developed a lot of
our technology using cytometry using
fluorescent proteins using cell sorters
but we view that the the complexity uh
and the number of products that
customers could make or people could
make
is way
more vast than what we could possibly
predict for a for a screen whether it be
empirical or rational
so that is you know in the end of the
day if you can do the design easily if
you can do the build easily if you can
generate your material easily the only
problem becomes for companies to really
focus on is how do you screen
effectively
great thank you our next question asks
did your approach to biological
engineering change if you are screening
versus selecting for an outcome
yeah that's um that's interesting so so
this idea of a screen versus selection
we should probably define that so the
idea of a screen is
you go through the process you generate
a bunch of diversity but you're looking
for
more of some products so you go back you
singulate the the individual cells you
form a colony you pick that colony you
array it in a 96 well plate this is what
we did with the lysine example for for
going back to the talk
and then you look and say okay which
colony which cell what population
produces more lysine
on the other hand if you're doing a
selection what you can do is take that
population of cells and expose it to uh
you know some sort of stress or some
sort of uh
something over time
and
what happens is in that case that you
can then
look and see okay which
uh phenotypes and and then relate that
back to the barcode get enriched so for
example let's say you want to look at uh
growing on glycerol so you could take
your yeast cell that has this massive
generated library you could grow it up
in glycerol and then after two days of
growing on glycerol go and say okay what
bar codes got enriched what barcodes are
now more present which barcodes fell out
which which designs spell out that are
no longer compatible with growth on
glycerol
so knowing if you're going to do a
screen or knowing if you're going to do
a selection does maybe change the types
of things that you uh would would
engineer in this approach i still think
the empirical methods are applicable but
maybe your rational methods may change
if you're in that screening versus
selection regime and looking at your
capacity to
find positive hits or winners if you
will
great thank you this next one has three
parts to it and it asks what is the
range of species in the onyx platform
compatible with what are the limitations
of the onyx platform in terms of species
compatibility and lastly what
characteristics does a species need to
have to be compatible with the onyx
platform
right so the onyx platform has its
release now is compatible with e coli
and saccharomyces although we are
looking to expand that range to other
organisms of industrial relevance
in the case of e coli we have two
standard strains called one is called uh
k strain uh also known as mg 1655 the
other one is is what we call b strains
this is the kind of uh protein
expression strain strains where
proteases are are knocked out
on the saccharomyces side we have two
strains one is s28c which is the kind of
standard academic laboratory strain of
saccharomyces the other one is senpique
and some variants the pk2 or cpk113d
both those cases the snpk2 strains are
considered to be more relevant to
industrial scale
and so there's a number of products made
by
companies that use this npk2 string
so those initial strains that we are are
supporting with that being said one of
the tools that script has developed is
what we call a custom strain assessment
library so this is a
library of about uh 900 edits
that are part of the um that we provide
to our customers and we allow them to
take their strain their e coli or their
saccharomyces strain that is not one of
our base strains uh deploy this library
against it and then look at the iterate
and see if that that the technology has
it exists is compatible with their
strains so this custom strain assessment
is a really important key part of making
sure that the onyx platform and the onyx
technology is compatible with um the
work that you are doing and with your
strain that you are trying to to work
with
great thank you this next question asks
how would you generate a combinatorial
library so do an expression optimize a
pathway of several enzymes
yeah so let's say you have
uh an example of a pathway that you know
it could either be a native pathway or a
heterologous pathway
it's a very simple process of you upload
your genome that includes that pathway
into the inscriptor designer software um
and in that script designer software you
then go to your you know those key genes
that are mapped and really easy to find
within the software
and let's say you want to do saturation
geogenesis you then take that gene and
you have a choice you can either pick
out individual residues and there's a
drop down menu that says what do you
want to do do you want to do a deletion
here you want to do a substitution you
want to do a change
and through that you can you can
basically say i want to change to every
other amino acid
you can do that on individual residues
or you can do it across the whole coding
sequence and then you just repeat that
six times um the first time i played
with the designer software so in my time
at amherst i worked on terpene pathways
it's related to the mavalenate pathway
that's native and yeast
once i learned the software which took
about a 15-20 minute tutorial i was able
to do saturation geogenesis across the
entire babalonate pathway across every
single gene it took me about 15 minutes
of clicking buttons to design that type
of library
so it's really software driven it's very
simple very
user interface positive that allows you
to take the native genes take your
heterologous genes once your genome is
uploaded you can make any of those
changes with a click of a button
and then you press order and you get a
library back in a couple of weeks and
then you go you know
transform it and and screen
awesome all right next question says
what are the challenges of incorporating
onyx to improve industrial strains
um
you know i think it starts with what we
talked about a second ago is that custom
strain assessment so let's look at a
compatibility of your strain are you
working in a half floyd are you working
in a diploid in the case of yeast are
you working in one of these standard
strains in e coli it's that customer
strain assessment that says hey
um let's look at at the
compatibility um and you know and then
if it's not completely compatible are
there some things that we can do are
there some things that we
um
know about uh you know your particular
strain it's instead of the salt or this
like that we can maybe change so the
instrument uh has some compatibility for
the most part the instrument is very
straightforward you you know press some
buttons and run the run the run the
instrument but
if there are some known limitations on
your particular industrial strain we
have the ability to work within that
within the instrument to to make changes
that may make it more
accessible to to your particular strain
for the most part we've found with our
early customers in industrial space
those tweaks really aren't necessary we
already have a couple of protocols in
place and the first protocol doesn't
work we can go to the second one and we
can get your strain to be compatible
pretty quickly
all right and it looks like we have time
for one more question and this one also
has two parts it asks are there plans to
extend implementation to bacterial
species other than e coli and if so what
are the main challenges of doing so
yeah i mean it is part of our our road
map um you know we're not going to
promise that it's going to be available
to tomorrow but it is part of the
roadmap it is part of the
technology that we are are actively
developing um you know in those other
bacterial species you can imagine that
there are certain species that are of of
high industrial relevance
um and we're looking towards those as
having the greatest impact at the end of
the day we want to kind of democratize
the bioeconomy
so finding those strains that are most
accessible
that there is demonstration of scale and
production at scale of important key
enzymes are what's kind of driving that
that road map we do expect as part of
the onyx platform
it was intentionally designed with some
flexibility so if we do have to change
our process and our parameters to make
it acceptable with new species
it doesn't require us making a new
instrument we can make the instrument
compatible with those species of
interest species like you know bacillus
or streptomyces or pseudomonas are
certainly ones that
we need to to look at and demonstrate
and and then provide to customers in the
in the future
well thank you again dr patrick westfall
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor in scripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone bye